This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If I asked you to think of the most famous architect in American history, even if you don't think you know anything at all about architecture, I bet you could take a guess. And I bet your guess would be... right. Frank Lloyd Wright. Frank Lloyd Wright, perhaps the greatest architect of the 20th century. The genius with a T-square has been called the paste center of modern-day architecture.
这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。如果我让你想出美国历史上最著名的建筑师，即使你认为自己对建筑一窍不通，我敢打赌你也能猜出来。而且我敢打赌你猜的会是……对的。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特（Frank Lloyd Wright）。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特，也许是20世纪最伟大的建筑师。这位使用丁字尺的天才被称为现代建筑的中心。
One of the most extraordinary man of art is that he has literally established the pace for innovations and new ideas in the field of architecture. Frank Lloyd Wright left a legacy of some of the most iconic and gorgeous buildings in the United States, like the Spiraling Guggenheim Museum in New York, the Falling Waterhouse in Pennsylvania, which straddles a waterfall, and the futuristic Marin Civic Center, which is the backdrop for Gatica, which is an awesome movie.
这位非凡的艺术大师真正为建筑领域的创新和新理念设定了步伐。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特留下了美国一些最具标志性和华丽的建筑遗产，比如纽约螺旋形的古根海姆博物馆、横跨瀑布的宾夕法尼亚州流水别墅，以及作为电影《千钧一发》（Gattaca）背景的未来主义风格马林县政务中心，那是一部很棒的电影。
And that is producer Avery Trouffleman. By the end of his career, Wright was on a level of celebrity, usually reserved for actors and rock stars. He was a household name, and he was on late-night talk shows. Some quarters have denounced Wright as an impractical visionary and a poppers windbag. He was a household name, and he was a character. He often wore this outfit that included a flowy cape and a hat and cane. He wrote manifestos, launched insults at other architects and loudly critiqued politicians,
那是制片人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Trouffleman）。到职业生涯末期，赖特的名气通常只有演员和摇滚明星才能享有。他是家喻户晓的人物，经常出现在深夜脱口秀节目中。一些人曾谴责赖特是一个不切实际的空想家和自大的吹牛者。他确实家喻户晓，而且个性鲜明。他经常穿着那种飘逸的斗篷，戴着帽子，拄着手杖。他撰写宣言，对其他建筑师进行人身攻击，并大声批评政客、
religion, and society. He declared himself the greatest architect who ever lived. He was unashamed. He's the early in life I had to choose between honest arrogance and hypocritical humility. I chose honest arrogance and have seen no occasion to change now. And Frank Lloyd Wright had this wildly scandalous private life. There were suits against him, property seed, jail,
宗教和社会。他宣称自己是有史以来最伟大的建筑师。他毫不羞愧。他说：“早年我必须在诚实的傲慢和虚伪的谦逊之间做出选择。我选择了诚实的傲慢，至今没发现有任何改变的必要。”弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的私生活极其荒唐。针对他的诉讼、财产查封、入狱，
finally divorce. The raw material for big, spicy headlines, Frank Lloyd Wright was the darling of a sensational press. But this bombastic character ultimately changed the field of architecture and introduced a new philosophy of building. Before many of Wright's iconic and famous structures were completed, before falling water, before the Guggenheim, before the Marin Civic Center, his most significant contribution to our everyday lives was something much more modest. A small, sturdy, inexpensive, and most importantly, very beautiful house designed with the American
最终离婚。作为大肆渲染的头条新闻的素材，弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特是煽情媒体的宠儿。但这位夸夸其谈的人物最终改变了建筑领域，并引入了一种新的建筑哲学。在赖特许多标志性和著名的建筑完工之前，在流水别墅之前，在古根海姆之前，在马林县政务中心之前，他对我们日常生活最重要的贡献是一些更朴实的东西。一栋小巧、坚固、廉价，最重要的是非常美丽的房子，专为美国
working class and mind, and it all started with a journalist from Milwaukee. In 1934, a Milwaukee journal reporter named Herbert Jacobs was assigned to take a drive over to Springgreen in Central Wisconsin. He was told to write about Tally Esson, Frank Lloyd Wright's home and studio. Jacobs didn't really know anything about architecture, and at that particular time he wasn't really interested in learning anything about it. Because Herbert Jacobs had other things on his mind. In that November of 1934, his wife was very, very pregnant. The night before his reporting trip, he had brought her to the hospital and stayed up with
工薪阶层设计，而这一切都始于密尔沃基的一位记者。1934年，密尔沃基《日报》的一名记者赫伯特·雅各布斯（Herbert Jacobs）被指派开车前往威斯康星州中部的斯普林格林。他被告知要写一篇关于塔里埃森（Taliesin）的文章，那是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的家和工作室。雅各布斯对建筑一无所知，当时他也没兴趣学习。因为赫伯特·雅各布斯当时有别的心事。1934年11月，他的妻子即将临盆。在报道行程的前一天晚上，他把她送进医院，并陪伴她
her until dawn. The nurse has assured her birth that he could go on his reporting trip without missing the birth. And so, he set out that morning alone. Blirriade, completely unprepared. He drove 120 miles through the chill, gray Wisconsin countryside for his assignment. To me, with Frank Lloyd Wright. Wright, who was 67 in 1934, couldn't have cared less about his appointment with Herbert
直到黎明。护士向她保证，他可以去出差而不会错过孩子的出生。于是，那天早上他独自出发了。毫无准备。他开车穿过寒冷、灰暗的威斯康星乡村，行驶了120英里去完成他的任务。去见弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特。1934年时年67岁的赖特，根本不在乎他与赫伯特·
Jacobs of the Milwaukee Journal. Actually, Wright forgot all about it, which wasn't unusual. He was known to blow off journalists. When Jacob arrived at Frank Lloyd Wright's compound, completely distracted by thoughts of his wife and their baby, he learned that the architect was actually on his way out the door. They got to talk for just over 10 minutes before Wright left abruptly saying, some of the boys will talk to you now.
雅各布斯的预约。事实上，赖特完全忘了这件事，这并不罕见。他以放记者鸽子而闻名。当雅各布斯到达弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的庄园时，他满脑子都是妻子和孩子，完全心不在焉，他得知这位建筑师实际上正要出门。他们交谈了不到10分钟，赖特就突然离开，说：“小伙子们会跟你谈的。”
The boys were Frank Lloyd Wright's apprentices. They had come to him from all over the world, and they're a part of a fellowship program that Wright established at his home in studio, a campus he called Tally Essin. Tally Essin, a Welsh word, meaning shining brow. Welsh because it was built on land settled by his family who were farmers from Wales, but the shining brow also has to do with Wright's building philosophy. So Tally Essin actually is built kind of on the brow, just like your brow of your head.
这些小伙子是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的学徒。他们从世界各地慕名而来，是赖在他家和工作室建立的奖学金项目的一部分，他称这个园区为塔里埃森（Taliesin）。塔里埃森是一个威尔士语单词，意为“闪耀的额头”。之所以用威尔士语，是因为它建在他家族定居的土地上，他的家人是来自威尔士的农民，但“闪耀的额头”也与赖特的建筑哲学有关。所以塔里埃森实际上是建在山脊上，就像你头部的额头一样。
The main Tally Essin building crawls around the side of a hill, almost like a crown. He felt that you should never build on top of a hill because that destroyed the integrity of the hill. This is Floyd Hamlin. He's an architect at Tally Essin. Also part of the faculty of the hill. This is Floyd Hamlin. He's an architect at Tally S. Also, part of the faculty of the Frank Lloyd Wright School of Architecture, and I've been here since starting as a apprentice back in 1987.
塔里埃森的主建筑沿着山坡蜿蜒，几乎像一个王冠。他认为你不应该在山顶上盖房子，因为那会破坏山的完整性。这是弗洛伊德·哈姆林（Floyd Hamlin）。他是塔里埃森的建筑师。也是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特建筑学院的教员，我从1987年开始在这里做学徒，一直待到现在。
Hamlin works and lives at Tally S. in full time. Here on Frank Lloyd Wright's family land, we're right used to play as a boy. So where are we now? So where are we now? So where are we? We are. This is just outside of Spring Green, Wisconsin.
哈姆林在塔里埃森全职工作和生活。就在弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特儿时玩耍的家族土地上。那么我们现在在哪里？我们现在在哪里？我们现在在哪里？我们就在威斯康星州斯普林格林郊外。
It's a very beautiful green valley with rolling hills. So he spent a lot of his summers working this land. So he was very familiar with the landscape. And this connection with the outdoors was really formative for right. He thought that architecture should help people live harmoniously with their environment rather than shield them from it. The house could become part of nature
这是一个非常美丽的绿色山谷，有起伏的丘陵。所以他花了很多夏天在这片土地上工作。因此，他对这里的景观非常熟悉。这种与户外的联系对赖特来说具有塑造意义。他认为建筑应该帮助人们与环境和谐相处，而不是将他们与环境隔绝。房子可以成为自然的一部分，
if it was made with local materials and had big windows and was oriented for just the right amount of sunlight. The orient, the house, just right so that you take advantage of what nature has to offer and you're living with nature rather than trying to fight against it. You know, living on the brow of the hill, not on top of it. This all folded into a concept, Frank Lloyd Wright called organic architecture. He wanted to spread this gospel to the next generation, which is why he returned to the valley he knew as a boy
如果它是用当地材料建造的，有大窗户，并且朝向能获得恰到好处的阳光。将房子朝向调整得恰到好处，这样你就能利用自然所提供的一切，与自然共存，而不是试图对抗它。你知道，住在山脊上，而不是山顶上。这一切都融入了一个概念，弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特称之为“有机建筑”。他想把这个福音传播给下一代，这就是为什么他回到了他儿时熟悉的那个山谷，
and established the Taliessan Fellowship. The fellowship was the thing that the Milwaukee Journal wanted Herbert Jacobs to cover in his article. When Jacobs drove into Taliessan that morning in 1934, the fellowship had been going on for two years, and it was hard for the public to wrap their minds around it, including this NBC announcer. The Talias and Fellowship. Just what is it?
并建立了塔里埃森奖学金项目。这个奖学金项目正是密尔沃基《日报》希望赫伯特·雅各布斯在文章中报道的内容。当雅各布斯1934年那天早上开车进入塔里埃森时，该项目已经进行了两年，公众很难理解它，包括这位NBC播音员。“塔里埃森奖学金。它到底是什么？”
A school and yet not a school. A colony of devoted men and women. A principality whose king is Frank Lloyd Wright. A parenthesis there called, not students, they are as Mr. Wright as the fingers of my hand. The apprentices had to pay $1,100 a year to attend the Tallyesson Fellowship, nearly 20 grand today, and it wasn't like an accredited institution or anything. Students had to do a lot of grunt work like bailing hay, plowing fields, and making meals. But they got to learn Frank Lloyd Wright's philosophy of architecture, and live with
“一所学校，却又不是学校。一群忠诚的男女组成的聚落。一个以弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特为王的公国。那里的人被称为，不是学生，他们就像赖特先生手上的手指一样。”学徒们每年必须支付1100美元才能参加塔里埃森奖学金项目，相当于今天的近2万美元，而且它也不是什么认证机构。学生们必须做很多苦力活，比如打草、耕地和做饭。但他们可以学习弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的建筑哲学，并与
him, and work with him, even though oftentimes is meant serving as an unpaid labor force. When Jacobs was getting his tour of Tally Essin, he described the apprentices as rather long-haired, smiling, and polite young men, who tried their best to explain to him what organic architecture means. Organic architecture is architecture of its time and of its place. You're not trying to make it look like something that it's not. Right thought that there should be no wallpaper to cover things up.
他一起生活和工作，尽管这往往意味着充当无薪劳动力。当雅各布斯参观塔里埃森时，他形容学徒们是“留着长发、面带微笑、彬彬有礼的年轻人”，他们尽力向他解释有机建筑的含义。有机建筑是属于其时代和地点的建筑。你不是试图让它看起来像它本不是的东西。赖特认为不应该用壁纸来遮盖东西。
No paint, no plaster. Wood should look like wood, stone should look like stone. Concrete should look like concrete. When Frank Lloyd Wright worked with plywood, he liked to leave the edge of the plywood exposed so that you saw those layers in there and that became part of the almost ornament or detail. Which was different from frilly traditional European style architecture with rococo gold ornaments and clofet chairs and parlors full of knick-knacks.
没有油漆，没有石膏。木头应该看起来像木头，石头应该看起来像石头。混凝土应该看起来像混凝土。当弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特使用胶合板时，他喜欢把胶合板的边缘露出来，这样你就能看到里面的层数，这几乎成了装饰或细节的一部分。这与带有洛可可式金色装饰、华丽椅子和摆满小摆设的客厅的繁琐传统欧洲风格建筑截然不同。
Just think of Victorian houses stuffed with lots of tiny rooms and covered in bright paint and lacy curtains. This idea of organic architecture wasn't just a break from these traditions. It was a break from new trends in modern architecture too. Cities all over the world were building huge, boxy, class and steel structures, designed to be hyper-sleep machines for living and working. Wright explains that these were simply not comfortable for human animals. They are like goldfish and a globe, and these houses that are so classified as they know
想想那些维多利亚时代的房子，塞满了许多小房间，覆盖着明亮的油漆和蕾丝窗帘。这种有机建筑的理念不仅是对这些传统的突破，也是对现代建筑新趋势的突破。世界各地的城市都在建造巨大的、方方正正的玻璃和钢结构建筑，旨在成为超高效的居住和工作机器。赖特解释说，这些建筑对人类动物来说根本不舒服。它们就像金鱼缸里的金鱼，这些房子被分类得如此细致，
are, they're not sensible, it's an abuse of privilege and an abuse of material. Frank Lloyd Wright took the traditional old materials and put them into sleek modern forms. His organic architecture was a new style, born in the United States. An organic architecture, a new sense of what constitutes humanity under harmonious conditions, a harmonious place in which to live and a harmonious way to live in it. But Franchloid Wright didn't explain this grand philosophy to the journalist Herbert Jacobs,
它们不合理，这是对特权的滥用，也是对材料的滥用。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特采用了传统的旧材料，并将它们置于时尚的现代形式中。他的有机建筑是一种在美国诞生的新风格。有机建筑，一种在和谐条件下构成人类的新感觉，一个和谐的居住场所，以及一种和谐的居住方式。但弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特并没有向记者赫伯特·雅各布斯解释这种宏大的哲学，
because Wright wasn't there. The apprentices did the best they could, but again, Jacobs was very distracted and was only thinking of his wife in the hospital. He thanked the two young men who showed him around Tallyesson and got back in his car. Jacobs later wrote, finally I started back to Milwaukee, learning on the way through a telephone call young man who showed him around Tallyesson and got back in his car. Jacob's later road. Funnily, I started back to Milwaukee, learning on the way through a telephone call to the
因为赖特当时不在场。学徒们尽了最大努力，但雅各布斯非常分心，满脑子想的都是在医院的妻子。他感谢了带他参观塔里埃森的那两个年轻人，回到了车里。雅各布斯后来写道：“最后我开始返回密尔沃基，在路上通过电话得知……”（带他参观塔里埃森的年轻人，回到了车里。雅各布斯后来写道：有趣的是，我开始返回密尔沃基，在路上通过电话得知）
hospital that I had become a father at about 11 o'clock that morning, at the very moment when I was interviewing right. Herbert Jacobs, his wife, Catherine, and their new daughter, lived in Milwaukee for two more years on his reporter's salary of $20 a week. This was in the mid-30s, the Great Depression. So when Herbert Jacobs was offered a slightly higher-paying job with a paper in the state capital of Madison, the family moved right away. and our newspaper man's price range, it was what we figured would be nice to live in. This is the voice of Herbert Jacobs himself from a 1956 NBC interview.
医院那边说，那天早上11点左右，就在我采访赖特的时候，我当爸爸了。赫伯特·雅各布斯、他的妻子凯瑟琳和他们的新生女儿在密尔沃基又住了两年，靠他每周20美元的记者薪水生活。那是30年代中期，大萧条时期。所以当赫伯特·雅各布斯得到一份薪水稍高的工作，在州首府麦迪逊的一家报社工作时，全家立刻搬走了。“在报社记者的价格范围内，这是我们认为住起来会很舒服的房子。”这是赫伯特·雅各布斯本人在1956年NBC采访中的声音。
When he and Catherine moved to Madison, they didn't see any houses they liked, or that they could afford. So a cousin of my wife had been out at Taliesin and Mr. Wright and suggested that we have Mr. Wright do something for us. Jacobs didn't really remember much about his first visit to Tally Aston two years ago. Any murmured something along the lines of very interesting, which his wife's cousin took as a yes. But he made an appointment for us to go out there and we went along with that idea.
当他和凯瑟琳搬到麦迪逊时，他们没看到任何他们喜欢或买得起的房子。所以“我妻子的一个表亲去过塔里埃森，见过赖特先生，建议我们让赖特先生为我们做点什么。”雅各布斯对两年前的第一次塔里埃森之行记忆模糊。他嘟囔了一些类似“非常有意思”的话，他妻子的表亲把它当作了同意。“但他为我们预约了去那里，我们就顺着这个想法去了。”
Then on the way out, my wife and I were trying to think, what is it that we can tell this great man, the architect of rich plants, what can we say to him that would interest him in our very small case? In the past, when Frank Lloyd Wright had designed private homes, they had not been for people like Herbert and Catherine Jacobs. Wright had designed gorgeous, wide homes
“然后在去那里的路上，我和妻子试图想，我们能告诉这位伟人、这位富豪的建筑师什么呢？我们能对他说什么才能让他对我们这种小案子感兴趣？”过去，当弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特设计私人住宅时，并不是为赫伯特和凯瑟琳·雅各布斯这样的人设计的。赖特设计过华丽、宽敞的住宅，
with broad roofs and expensive living rooms for wealthy people. His constructions were masterpieces. They were works of art, and they were expensive. So we put it as a sort of challenge. What the country needs is a decent $5,000 house. Can you build one? In today's money, $5,000 is about $85,000. That's a pretty reasonably priced house in most real estate markets. Mr. Wright told us that we were the first clients that ever asked him to build a little cost house.
有着宽阔的屋顶和昂贵的客厅，是为富人设计的。他的建筑是杰作。它们是艺术品，而且很昂贵。所以我们把它当作一种挑战。“这个国家需要的是一栋体面的5000美元的房子。你能盖一栋吗？”按今天的货币计算，5000美元大约是8.5万美元。在大多数房地产市场，这都是一栋价格相当合理的房子。赖特先生告诉我们，我们是第一批要求他建造小成本住宅的客户。
He said, for 20 years, you've been wanting to build one, but no one ever asked him to. Now Wright had long wanted to make a more democratic form of housing, even early in his career. He had been playing around with inexpensive methods of building and other structures, and he had a lot of concepts that he had been scheming around urban planning. But now, Wright had the chance to make some of his concepts a reality. He had the willing clients, and he had time on his hands. In 1936, he was in a bit of a slump in his career. People couldn't afford fancy big new homes.
他说，20年来，他一直想盖一栋，但从来没有人要求他这样做。现在，赖特早就想创造一种更民主的住房形式，甚至在他职业生涯早期也是如此。他一直在尝试廉价的建筑方法和其他结构，并且他有很多关于城市规划的构想。但现在，赖特有机会将他的一些构想变为现实。他有愿意配合的客户，而且他有时间。1936年，他的职业生涯处于低谷。人们买不起昂贵的新大房子。
Again, it was the depression, and a number of big projects had been cancelled, and also Wright had already been practicing for decades, and he was slowly getting written off as a husband. And then incomes this young, open-minded couple, Wright could tell them his philosophy and teach them how to live well through good architecture. Then he said, do you really want a $5,000 house? You said most people want a $10,000 house for $5,000. Are you willing to give up the things
同样，那是大萧条时期，许多大型项目被取消了，而且赖特已经从业几十年了，他正慢慢被视为过气人物。然后这对年轻、思想开放的夫妇来了，赖特可以告诉他们他的哲学，并通过好的建筑教他们如何过上好生活。然后他说：“你们真的想要一栋5000美元的房子吗？你们知道大多数人想要的是价值1万美元却只花5000美元的房子。你们愿意放弃那些
that you have to give up? Mr. Wright made a list of the things that the Jacobs would have to do without if they really wanted a $5,000 house. Tile bathrooms, extra trim, finish and things like that. Are you willing to give those up? We didn't know anything about it, and we said, sure, it's okay with us.
必须放弃的东西吗？”赖特先生列出了一份清单，如果他们真的想要一栋5000美元的房子，雅各布斯夫妇就必须放弃这些东西。瓷砖浴室、额外的装饰线条、饰面等等。“你们愿意放弃这些吗？”我们对此一无所知，我们说：“当然，我们没问题。”
Herbert and Catherine Jacobs didn't know it at the time, but that modest little house that Frank Lloyd Wright was to build for them would be the most practical expression of his ideology. The Jacobs would own the first house in a movement that right called euconia. The house that Herbert Jacobs built was the first of the euconian houses. Euconian, a right word meaning the United States is it ought to be at its democratic zenith.
赫伯特和凯瑟琳·雅各布斯当时并不知道，弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特为他们建造的那栋朴实的小房子，将成为他意识形态最实际的体现。雅各布斯一家将拥有赖特称之为“尤索尼亚”（Usonia）运动中的第一栋房子。赫伯特·雅各布斯建造的房子是第一栋尤索尼亚住宅。尤索尼亚，一个赖特创造的词，意为“美国正处于其民主的巅峰”。
Euconia was Frank Lloyd Wright's name for the United States of North America. In Wright's vision, euconia would be a country full of modest, well-made, beautiful, comfortable little houses that the working class could afford. These Eusonian homes would inspire, educate, and write believed, create a new culture for all Americans. I believe now people are going to know what constitutes good architecture and of course good living has to go with it. Good conduct also, good dressing too,
尤索尼亚是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特对北美合众国的称呼。在赖特的愿景中，尤索尼亚将是一个充满朴实、制作精良、美丽、舒适的小房子的国家，工薪阶层都能负担得起。这些尤索尼亚住宅将激励、教育人们，赖特相信，这将为所有美国人创造一种新文化。“我相信现在人们会知道什么是好的建筑，当然好的生活也随之而来。良好的行为也是，良好的着装也是，”
because you wouldn't dress in a loud and vulgar way in a quiet and beautiful room. All these good things are dependent more or less one on the other and add up to something we call culture. It's only by a natural growth that you can attain culture. Right believe the way to build a better American culture was not on mass, not in apartment buildings or cookie cutter developments. It was to be catered to the individual.
“因为你不会在一个安静而美丽的房间里穿得大声而庸俗。所有这些美好的事物或多或少相互依赖，加起来就是我们所说的文化。只有通过自然生长，你才能获得文化。”赖特相信，建立更好的美国文化的方法不是通过大众，不是通过公寓楼或千篇一律的开发项目。而是要迎合个人。
Culture is not for the club. Culture is an individual thing. And that's what our forefathers struck when they declared that the individual is sovereign. Which, to Frank Lloyd Wright, meant that the masses should be unmasked. They should spread out away from the city. Well, the city, of course, is a thing of the past. There was a time during the Middle Ages when there was the only source of culture. There was no way of acquiring this thing we call culture
“文化不是为了俱乐部。文化是个人的事情。这就是我们的先辈在宣布个人是主权者时所强调的。”这对于弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特来说，意味着大众应该“去大众化”。他们应该从城市中分散开来。“嗯，城市当然是过去的事物了。在中世纪，曾经有一段时间，它是文化的唯一来源。没有办法获得我们所说的这种文化，”
except by direct contact, you see. But for right, that wasn't true anymore. People were connected to culture through radio and telephones and automobiles. They have transportation, speed, listening, this, we're using now. It's no longer essential for people to crowd together, anywhere. That was Frank Lloyd Wright's vision for America, and it would start to become reality in 1936 with the Jacobs House, which he called Eusonea 1.
“除非通过直接接触，你明白吗。”但对赖特来说，那不再是事实了。人们通过收音机、电话和汽车与文化相连。他们有交通、速度、倾听，我们现在正在使用的这些。人们不再有必要挤在一起，在任何地方。这就是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特对美国的愿景，它将在1936年随着雅各布斯住宅开始成为现实，他称之为“尤索尼亚1号”。
Jacob's House was one of the first ones built. This was just a wide open farmland when it was built out here. This is Bill Martinelli, manager of Eusonea 1. It's in a suburban street outside of Madison, now lined with little suburban houses, but Eusonea1 really stands out. Even if you don't know what it is and you're just driving by, because from a street,
“雅各布斯住宅是建造的第一批住宅之一。它建成时，这里只是一片广阔的农田。”这是比尔·马蒂内利（Bill Martinelli），尤索尼亚1号的经理。它位于麦迪逊郊外的一条郊区街道上，现在两旁都是小型的郊区住宅，但尤索尼亚1号确实很突出。即使你不知道它是什么，只是开车经过，因为从街道上看，
it almost just looks like a beautiful wooden wall. The house turns its back on the road. Well, I want to get inside or if we go around back, you'll see the whole back of the house is all glass. It's all open to the back. And you know, we did that intentionally that kind of closed it off to the street and then open it up to the back. As right saw it, the point of the house was not to have a big facade
它几乎看起来就像一堵美丽的木墙。房子背对着马路。“嗯，我想进去看看，或者如果我们绕到后面，你会看到房子的整个背面都是玻璃。它完全向后方开放。你知道，我们是故意这样做的，把面向街道的一面封闭起来，然后向后方开放。”在赖特看来，房子的重点不是要有一个巨大的立面，
to show off to your neighbors with a useless and wasteful patch of lawn in the front in a grand entry way. No. The house should be built for residents, not onlookers. Also, from the street, you can see that there's no garage. A car is parked under a wooden awning, just a little flat roof with no sidewalls. This is the car port, a term that Frank Lloyd Wright coined. Well, this is the car port of the house.
向邻居炫耀，在前面有一个无用且浪费的草坪和宏伟的入口。不。房子应该是为居民建造的，而不是为旁观者。此外，从街上你可以看到没有车库。汽车停在木制遮阳棚下，只是一个没有侧墙的小平屋顶。这就是“车棚”（carport），一个弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特创造的术语。“嗯，这就是房子的车棚。”
Consider the first named car port that was a term that Wright came up with. This was one of the many tiny ways Wright kept costs down, and also the Carport was an education in lifestyle. Without a garage, the Jacobs wouldn't have space to store their junk. They'd have to simply minimize their possessions and toss what they didn't need. But the Carport isn't purely utilitarian. The woodwork on the Carport roof has this lovely geometric pattern. It was like these wood kind of stripes in the ceiling. Yeah, it's funny. When I heard about the carport and like scene pictures of it, I didn't expect it to be so beautiful and
“被认为是第一个命名的车棚，这是赖特想出的一个术语。”这是赖特降低成本的许多微小方式之一，而且车棚也是一种生活方式的教育。没有车库，雅各布斯一家就没有空间存放他们的垃圾。他们必须简单地精简他们的财产，扔掉他们不需要的东西。但车棚并非纯粹实用。车棚屋顶上的木制品有一种可爱的几何图案。“就像天花板上的这些木条纹。是的，很有趣。当我听说车棚并看到它的照片时，我没想到它会这么漂亮，而且……”
like, it's really nice. It's the thing in this house, the more you look around the more, the more you see, you know, like with the ceiling here in the carport, you wouldn't expect that. When you get inside, you'll see the same thing. Euconia 1 is full of small, elegant details. Can we go inside? Sure. A warm in here.
“就像，它真的很好。这是这栋房子的特点，你看得越多，看到的就越多，你知道，就像这里的车棚天花板，你不会想到这一点。当你进去时，你会看到同样的事情。”尤索尼亚1号充满了小巧、优雅的细节。“我们可以进去吗？”“当然。里面很暖和。”
Oh, wow. You see how the sun comes in. It's so red, like the brick and the wood and the. Your eye kind of gets drawn in. Euconia 1 is one floor. And inside, it's pretty much one room and a loud cat. The space is all open. No walls between living room, dining room, kitchen. That was kind of innovative for the time.
“哦，哇。你看阳光是怎么进来的。它是如此红，就像砖头和木头，还有……你的眼睛会被吸引进去。”尤索尼亚1号是一层楼。里面基本上是一个房间和一只吵闹的猫。空间完全开放。客厅、餐厅、厨房之间没有墙。这在当时是相当创新的。
The kitchen is an alcove adjacent to the living slash dining space with no door. It's a very, very tiny area. This is the kitchen. It's just a little bit wider than the length of my arms I think. Well, each foot plate, each foot square probably. There's a small hallway with tiny bedrooms but mostly the one main room is the focus. It's where you're supposed to eat, relax, read, live all together. Again Herbert Jacobs. Mr. Wright is an advocate of the open plan and housing that is the removal of the boxes within boxes, sort of thing, so that you don't have many partitions.
厨房是一个与客厅/餐厅空间相邻的壁龛，没有门。这是一个非常、非常小的区域。“这就是厨房。我想它只比我双臂展开的长度宽一点点。嗯，每英尺板，每平方英尺可能。”有一个带小卧室的小走廊，但主要是那个主房间是焦点。那是你应该吃饭、放松、阅读、生活在一起的地方。再次回到赫伯特·雅各布斯。“赖特先生是开放式平面和住房的倡导者，也就是移除盒子里的盒子，那种东西，这样你就不会有太多的隔断。”
The temptation is to be together much more. The open plan was pretty novel, and it was cost was cost saving to not have many walls. The Euconian house is full of these clever, less expensive solutions like the lights on the ceiling. So that's just a steel channel with the wires just laying in there and then bare-sock, it's bare bulbs. So that's considered the first track lighting another first to the house. And now you see track lighting everywhere, where you see lights or bulbs affixed to a single beam. That's a euconian invention. Other innovations euconia popularized include the use of flat roofs, built in furniture,
“诱惑是更多地在一起。”开放式平面相当新颖，而且没有太多的墙壁可以节省成本。尤索尼亚住宅充满了这些巧妙、低成本的解决方案，比如天花板上的灯。“所以那只是一个钢槽，电线就放在里面，然后是裸露的灯座，是裸露的灯泡。所以这被认为是第一种轨道照明，房子的另一个第一。现在你到处都能看到轨道照明，当你看到固定在单根横梁上的灯或灯泡时。那是尤索尼亚的发明。”尤索尼亚普及的其他创新包括使用平屋顶、内置家具，
and heated floors. Herbert Jacobs loved those heated floors. Floor heating, now very general, but at that time there were no floor he did residences in this country. All of these innovations were meant to help the family live well and frugally. They saved money while they lived in the house, and they had also saved costs in the construction of the house. But right used some other cost-saving measures that were kind of cheating. Like, he stole some bricks from another building of his that he was constructing nearby. Well, Wright didn't steal the bricks himself. He sent a bunch of his apprentices over to
和地暖。赫伯特·雅各布斯喜欢那些地暖。“地板采暖，现在很普遍，但在当时，这个国家没有地板采暖的住宅。”所有这些创新都是为了帮助家庭生活得既好又节俭。他们在居住在房子里时节省了钱，而且他们在建造房子时也节省了成本。但赖特使用了一些其他节省成本的措施，有点像作弊。比如，他从他附近正在建造的另一栋建筑里偷了一些砖块。“嗯，赖特并没有亲自偷砖块。他派了一群学徒去……”
Racine Wisconsin, where his design for the Johnson Wax Building was under construction. He told the apprentices to grab as many bricks as they could and bring them back to Madison. If you're familiar with the Johnson Wax building, the corners are curved so you can see some of these bricks are Convec and some are concave. Well those would depend like corner bricks Another way right kept costs down was by taking a huge pay cut himself Bill I paid was for $5,500 which included Mr. Wright's fee of $450. By hook or by crook, Wright did it. He met his challenge of building a beautiful house
威斯康星州拉辛，他的庄臣办公楼（Johnson Wax Building）设计正在那里施工。他告诉学徒们尽可能多地拿砖块，并把它们带回麦迪逊。如果你熟悉庄臣办公楼，角落是弯曲的，所以你可以看到其中一些砖块是凸的，有些是凹的。嗯，那些取决于像角落砖块。赖特降低成本的另一种方式是他自己大幅减薪。“比尔，我付的钱是5500美元，其中包括赖特先生450美元的费用。”无论如何，赖特做到了。他完成了建造一栋美丽的房子，
that Herbert and Catherine could afford. I mean, it wasn't perfect. It was a total adjustment for the family. And the house had problems with rain drainage and little things were missing, like initially Wright forgot to put screens in the windows. Which were the kinds of complaints right got a lot. He mostly focused on aesthetics and principles of building
赫伯特和凯瑟琳负担得起的挑战。我的意思是，它并不完美。这对家庭来说是一个完全的调整。房子有雨水排水问题，一些小东西缺失了，比如最初赖特忘了在窗户上安装纱窗。这是赖特经常收到的那种抱怨。他主要关注美学和建筑原则，
rather than practicalities. And ultimately, the Jacob's house was small. After Herbert and Catherine had two more children, they couldn't fit into the house anymore. And so after six years of living in Eusonia one, the Jacob's family would move off to the countryside, where Frank Lloyd Wright would design them a second Eusonian house. But Herbert Jacobs thought of their first home very fondly.
而不是实用性。最终，雅各布斯住宅很小。在赫伯特和凯瑟琳又生了两个孩子后，他们再也住不下这栋房子了。因此，在尤索尼亚1号住了六年之后，雅各布斯一家搬到了乡村，弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特在那里为他们设计了第二栋尤索尼亚住宅。但赫伯特·雅各布斯对他们的第一个家怀有深厚的感情。
Living in that house was fantastically wonderful. I think it would be nice if a lot more families had that same sort of thing happen to them. Mr. Wright thought so too. He thought everybody should live in a house, designed by him and, you know, the dishes and clothes designed by him and all of furniture and... He did design a lot of his furniture. And in at least one case,
“住在那个房子里真是太美妙了。我想如果更多的家庭能有同样的经历会很好。”赖特先生也这么认为。他认为每个人都应该住在他设计的房子里，你知道，餐具和衣服也是他设计的，所有的家具和……”他确实设计了很多家具。而且至少有一次，
he did design a dress for the wife of a client. This was all about changing culture, one home at a time. Frank Lloyd Wright wanted to redesign America, and by that token, Americans. Good design he thought would make a kinder, more beautiful, more enlightened country. Nowadays, Eusonian houses may be seen the country wide. You don't need a guide book. By 1939 Wright had built Eusonian homes all over the country, including houses in Alabama, California, Illinois, Michigan, and Virginia.
他确实为一位客户的妻子设计了一件连衣裙。这一切都是关于改变文化，一次一个家庭。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特想重新设计美国，进而重新设计美国人。他认为好的设计会使国家变得更友善、更美丽、更开明。如今，尤索尼亚住宅可能在全国各地都能看到。你不需要指南。到1939年，赖特已经在全国各地建造了尤索尼亚住宅，包括阿拉巴马州、加利福尼亚州、伊利诺伊州、密歇根州和弗吉尼亚州的住宅。
But he wanted to build more. He wanted to have a central factory that made prefabricated Euconian parts modifiable for each client depending on their needs for space and site conditions. And originally the whole idea was all these walls would be manufactured in a factory that never really happened. This was all site built. Frank Lloyd writes factory for Euconian Homes never came to pass. And it became increasingly clear to write that the $5,000 price tag for Euconian Homes
但他想建造更多。他想拥有一个中央工厂，制造预制的尤索尼亚部件，根据每个客户对空间和场地条件的需求进行修改。最初的想法是，所有的墙壁都将在工厂制造，但这从未真正实现。这都是现场建造的。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的尤索尼亚住宅工厂从未实现。而且赖特越来越清楚，尤索尼亚住宅5000美元的价格标签，
just wasn't feasible after the Depression. Also Wright's career picked up shortly after Eusonia won. He started getting bigger commissions, the ones we all know him for, like fallen water. Among the Wright houses, none has been more widely publicized than the Pennsylvania home of Edgar Kaufman, which straddles the waterfall. Wright worked on Eusonia homes up until near the very end of his life. But it was a group of his apprentices that would carry on his vision by building an entire community of Euconian houses.
在大萧条之后根本不可行。此外，赖特的职业生涯在尤索尼亚1号之后不久就有了起色。他开始接到更大的委托，那些我们都知道他的项目，比如流水别墅。“在赖特的住宅中，没有比埃德加·考夫曼（Edgar Kaufman）的宾夕法尼亚住宅更广为人知的了，它横跨瀑布。”赖特一直致力于尤索尼亚住宅的设计，直到他生命尽头。但正是他的一群学徒通过建造整个尤索尼亚住宅社区，延续了他的愿景。
Turn right onto Euconia Road. Up next after the break, a trip to Euconia, New York, to see what became of Frank Lloyd Wright's vision and how these little houses have affected the ways we live. The future of architecture is the future of the human race. The two are one. If humanity has a future, it is architecture. That is architect Frank Lloyd Wright, who never shied away from making grand statements about architecture, or himself. I have been accused of saying I was the greatest architect in the world and if I had said so,
“右转进入尤索尼亚路。”休息后，下一站，前往纽约尤索尼亚，看看弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的愿景变成了什么样，以及这些小房子如何影响了我们的生活方式。“建筑的未来就是人类的未来。两者是一体的。如果人类有未来，那就是建筑。”这就是建筑师弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特，他从不回避对建筑或他自己发表宏大的声明。“我被指责说我是世界上最伟大的建筑师，如果我这么说了，”
I don't think it would be very arrogant. Wright believed that the buildings we live in affect the kinds of people we become, the tastes we have, and the comforts we seek. And he said that he could rebuild the entire culture of the United States. He claimed that he could change the nation by changing its architecture. I did say that, and it's true. It's amazing that I could do for this country. And a big part of his plan, his philosophy, his proposed building system, was called
“我不认为这会非常傲慢。”赖特相信，我们居住的建筑会影响我们成为什么样的人、我们拥有的品味以及我们寻求的舒适。他说他可以重建整个美国的文化。他声称他可以通过改变建筑来改变国家。“我确实说过，这是真的。我能为这个国家做的事情真是太神奇了。”而他的计划、他的哲学、他提出的建筑系统的一个重要部分，被称为
usonia. Here again is Avery Trouffleman. Wright's ideas about living in harmony with nature, using organic materials in a modern way, and creating affordable democratic housing had inspired a new generation of architects, so much so, that they would go on to found an entire community based on writing and principles. Turn right onto Euconia Road. Nestled in Levy Hills near Pleasantville, New York, about an hour north of Manhattan, is a little village called Euconia.
“尤索尼亚”。再次请出艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。赖特关于与自然和谐相处、以现代方式使用有机材料以及创造负担得起的民主住房的理念，激励了新一代建筑师，以至于他们后来创立了一个基于赖特原则的完整社区。“右转进入尤索尼亚路。”坐落在纽约州普莱森特维尔附近的利维山（Levy Hills），曼哈顿以北约一小时车程处，有一个叫尤索尼亚的小村庄。
All the homes have low flat roofs. They're tucked away into the trees, so you can hardly see them on lush summer days. It almost looks like some sort of star wars planet, fit for suburban e-walks. There's no big welcome sign, no gift shop or leaflet, but in the middle of the community, there is a plaque. Eusonia Homes, a cooperative was founded in 1944 by idealistic young families to pursue the dream of owning a modern, affordable home in the country following World War II. The cooperative was started by a couple of right disciples who had studied at
所有的房子都有低矮的平屋顶。它们隐藏在树林中，所以在郁郁葱葱的夏日里你几乎看不见它们。它看起来几乎像某种星球大战的星球，适合郊区的伊沃克人（Ewoks）。没有巨大的欢迎标志，没有礼品店或传单，但在社区中心，有一块牌匾。“尤索尼亚住宅，一个合作社，由理想主义的年轻家庭于1944年创立，旨在追求二战后在乡村拥有现代、负担得起的住宅的梦想。”这个合作社是由几位赖特的门徒发起的，他们曾在
Frank Lloyd Wright School, Tally Essin, most notably a man named David Hanken. And although Wright would be involved with the project, it was Hanken who guided it, as the black says. This land was acquired in December 1946 and in April 1947, Frank Lloyd Wright, the supervising architect, sent the unique site plan. The site plan put 40 some houses on circular properties without fences so that the property boundaries would flow
弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特学校、塔里埃森学习，其中最著名的是一个叫大卫·汉肯（David Hanken）的人。虽然赖特会参与这个项目，但正如牌匾所说，是汉肯引导了它。这片土地是在1946年12月获得的，1947年4月，作为监督建筑师的弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特发送了独特的场地规划。该规划将40多栋房子放在圆形地块上，没有围栏，这样地块边界就会流动
into each other. Homes wouldn't be on little square plots with white picket fences. David Hanken and his family looked for for other similarly-minded people who could come and join their community and invest in it. And among those idealistic young people was Roland Reisley. He and his wife had just been married in 1950. We had no money, we had no children, we were both only children. We wanted to plant our roots and start a family.
进入彼此。住宅不会建在带有白色栅栏的小方块地块上。大卫·汉肯和他的家人寻找其他志同道合的人，他们可以加入他们的社区并投资它。在这些理想主义的年轻人中，有罗兰·赖斯利（Roland Reisley）。他和他的妻子刚在1950年结婚。“我们没钱，我们没孩子，我们都是独生子女。我们想扎根并组建家庭。”
And we heard from a friend that there's a community in Northern Westchester that's building affordable homes supervised by Frank Lloyd Wright. This building project had a communal mortgage. They would pay for the houses together. On land, they all owned. It's a cooperative. Let's take a look. Curious. And we came up here and there were already 10 or 11 homes that were On land, they all owned. It's a cooperative. Let's take a look, curious.
“我们从朋友那里听说，在威彻斯特北部有一个社区，正在建造由弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特监督的经济适用房。”这个建筑项目有共同抵押贷款。他们将一起支付房子的费用。在他们共同拥有的土地上。这是一个合作社。让我们看看。好奇。我们来到这里，已经有10或11栋房子（在他们共同拥有的土地上。这是一个合作社。让我们看看，好奇。）
And we came up here, and there were already 10 or 11 homes that were near in completion or beginning to be occupied. We were welcomed with open arms, and the enthusiasm of the people who were here and talking about their project was infectious. And we were hooked. We decided that we'll join the community. But it wasn't all a big romantic adventure. It was a real risk. First of all, first was radical.
我们来到这里，已经有10或11栋房子接近完工或开始有人入住。我们受到了热烈的欢迎，这里的人们谈论他们的项目时的热情具有感染力。我们被迷住了。我们决定加入这个社区。但这并不全是浪漫的冒险。这是一个真正的风险。首先，首先是激进的。
It's not these days that's called mid-century modern, but the architecture then was radical. Meaning, these homes were so strange looking to the larger world that the people who chose to live in them were seen as radical. And in some ways, they were. Some of them were lefty Jews from the Bronx with socialist ideals about land ownership. The true cooperative that we were was radical. True cooperative in the sense that no one owned their house.
现在这被称为“中世纪现代”，但当时的建筑是激进的。意思是，这些房子在更大的世界看来是如此奇怪，以至于选择住在里面的人被视为激进分子。在某些方面，他们确实是。其中一些是来自布朗克斯的左翼犹太人，有着关于土地所有权的社会主义理想。我们作为真正的合作社是激进的。真正的合作社，意味着没有人拥有自己的房子。
Yes. Also, this was a financial risk, since the houses were not as cheap as they were supposed to be. The supposed $5,000 cost turned out it was not a realistic number. During an after-world war two, materials and labor became more expensive, and the building of usonian homes involved special skills and custom fixtures, and the houses ended up being double or triple their price estimates. The Reisley's house was over 20 grand, but the
是的。此外，这是一种财务风险，因为房子的价格并不像预期的那么便宜。所谓的5000美元成本结果并不是一个现实的数字。在二战期间和之后，材料和劳动力变得更加昂贵，尤索尼亚住宅的建造涉及特殊技能和定制固定装置，房子最终的价格是他们估计的两到三倍。赖斯利家的房子超过2万美元，但
members of Usonia would not be deterred. We were determined to go forward with this. We were all very optimistic. Peel would come occasionally to see these houses under construction. You got to come and see Insania. When Roland and his wife signed up for the community, they thought they'd work with one of the Tallyesson graduates to design their house, not the master himself. We didn't dream of approaching Frank Lloyd Wright, I mean, really. Who would throw such a thing? But Frank Lloyd Wright did in fact want to design Roland's house.
尤索尼亚的成员们并没有被吓倒。“我们决心推进这个项目。我们都非常乐观。”赖特偶尔会来看看这些正在建造的房子。“你一定要来看看尤索尼亚。”当罗兰和他的妻子报名参加这个社区时，他们以为他们会和塔里埃森的毕业生之一合作设计他们的房子，而不是大师本人。“我们没梦想过接近弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特，我的意思是，真的。谁会做这种事？”但弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特确实想设计罗兰的房子。
They met up in New York, and they exchanged letters and ideas about the plans, and Roland went out to see Wright at Tally Essin. And it was a real person. You could talk to him. You could exchange a joke. I mean, people don't see him that way. But there it was. Roland was 26. Wright was 83. He said, come on, Roland. Sit down. You're my client. I'm your architect.
他们在纽约见面，交换了关于计划的信件和想法，罗兰去塔里埃森见了赖特。“他是一个真实的人。你可以和他交谈。你可以开个玩笑。我的意思是，人们不那样看他。但事实就是这样。”罗兰当时26岁。赖特83岁。他说：“来吧，罗兰。坐下。你是我的客户。我是你的建筑师。”
I'll redesign your house as many times as I have to until I've satisfied all of your needs. You have to speak up if you don't, you'll redesign your house as many times as I have to until I've satisfied all of your needs. You have to speak up if you don't you'll take what you get." Roland's house would be one of three in Eusonia, New York that Frank Lloyd Wright designed himself. About five years after the Riesley's moved in, when Roland and his wife had kids, Frank Lloyd Wright added an extension to their house. In fact, Roland is the last living owner of a Frank Lloyd Wright Eustonian home built specially for him, and he still lives in it.
“我会重新设计你的房子，直到我满足了你所有的需求。如果你不满意，你必须说出来，否则你就会得到什么就是什么。”罗兰的房子将是纽约尤索尼亚由弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特亲自设计的三栋房子之一。在赖斯利一家搬进去大约五年后，当罗兰和他的妻子有了孩子，弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特为他们的房子增加了一个扩建部分。事实上，罗兰是最后一位于弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特尤索尼亚住宅中居住的在世业主，这栋房子是专门为他建造的，他至今仍住在里面。
I came to realize, after some years living here, that there had not been a day in my life when I didn't see something beautiful, even the terrible days that occur in every life. The house is completely usonian, with a simple carport and sumptuous wooden walls that almost glow and one big main room and a tiny kitchen. It almost feels like you're outside because it has these big glass windows with long roof overhangs to draw the eye out towards the thick forest of trees just outside. I think that it has had an effect on me in many ways.
在住在这里几年后，我意识到，我生命中没有哪一天看不到美丽的事物，即使是每个人生活中都会经历的那些糟糕的日子。这座房子完全是乌索尼式的，有一个简单的车棚、几乎会发光的华丽木墙、一个大的主房间和一个小厨房。它让人感觉仿佛置身室外，因为它有巨大的玻璃窗和长长的屋檐，将视线引向窗外茂密的森林。我认为它在许多方面对我产生了影响。
The neuroscientists say that that kind of sense reduces stress and is good for your emotional health. And maybe good for physical health too. I'm 92 years old. I'm pretty good shape in 92. Also. And I attribute that partly. I mean who knows. I'd like to attribute that to experience beauty around me for most of my life which is quite remarkable. As Roland sees it, Frank Lloyd writes idea that better architecture could create a better way of life has been entirely true. We could depend on each other if there was a problem or a need.
神经科学家说，这种感觉可以减轻压力，对你的情绪健康有益。也许对身体健康也有好处。我已经92岁了。92岁的我身体状况相当不错。而且，我把这部分归功于……我是说谁知道呢。我愿意把它归功于我一生中大部分时间都在体验周围的美，这非常了不起。正如罗兰所见，弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特关于更好的建筑可以创造更好的生活方式的理念是完全正确的。如果遇到问题或需要，我们可以互相依靠。
The kids are all, they're all the adults by their first name. You have to say that children growing up here had 50 aunts and uncles in New Sonya. For the first 40 years of Euconia New York, only 12 of the 48 houses changed hands. Six are those two next only 12 of the 48 houses changed hands. Six of those to next generation members of the community. There were only two devices. I had to joke, they couldn't decide who'd get the house. But life started to move at different paces for people living in Euconia.
孩子们对所有的成年人都直呼其名。你不得不说，在乌索尼亚长大的孩子在乌索尼亚有50个叔叔阿姨。在乌索尼亚（纽约州）的前40年里，48栋房子中只有12栋易主。其中6栋传给了社区的下一代成员。只有两起离婚。我不得不开玩笑说，他们无法决定谁该得到房子。但乌索尼亚居民的生活开始以不同的节奏进行。
Suddenly, they weren't all new young families. They were all groups of people in different phases with different needs. And when it was time for homes to change hands, perspective buyers were thrown off by the cooperative nature of the village. In the first decades of Eusonia, members didn't own their homes. We decided very reluctantly to grant title to the individual home sites to each member, while retaining all of our common land as a cooperative. And that made a big difference. Suddenly, people were more willing to look at them.
突然间，他们不再全是年轻的新家庭。他们成了处于不同阶段、有不同需求的人群。当房子需要易主时，潜在买家被村庄的合作性质所困扰。在乌索尼亚的最初几十年里，成员们并不拥有他们的房屋。我们非常不情愿地决定将个人住宅用地的所有权授予每个成员，同时保留我们所有的公共土地作为合作社。这产生了巨大的影响。突然间，人们更愿意考虑这些房子了。
But if you're not Roland Reisley and your house wasn't custom built for you by Frankwood Wright himself, the Usonia houses can be a bit of an adjustment. Today, most of the homes in Usonia, New York have been expanded. Any and all new additions have been built in a usonian style, using local materials, flat roofs, big glass windows, and writing sensibilities. They have to be built that way. While the outsides are not landmark, they are governed by the board of usonia, the insides are not at all.
但如果你不是罗兰·赖斯利，你的房子也不是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特本人为你定制的，那么乌索尼亚的房子可能需要一点适应。今天，纽约州乌索尼亚的大多数房屋都进行了扩建。所有的新增部分都是以乌索尼亚风格建造的，使用当地材料、平屋顶、大玻璃窗和赖特式的审美。它们必须以这种方式建造。虽然外观没有被列为地标，但它们受乌索尼亚董事会的管理，而内部则完全不受限制。
This is Evan Kingsley. He's one of the newcomers to usonia. Relatively. He's been there since 2003. But I think for the most part, those of us who have chosen to move here are really sensitive to the aesthetic of the interior. But there's one specific part of the interior that has changed in a lot of the Eusonian homes. We've completely redone the kitchen. As was the case in most Eusonian homes, kitchen in Evans' home was this little alcove, very efficient and very, very tiny.
这是埃文·金斯利。他是乌索尼亚的新成员之一。相对而言。他从2003年就在那里了。但我认为，我们这些选择搬到这里的人，在很大程度上对室内美学非常敏感。但室内有一个特定的部分在许多乌索尼亚住宅中发生了变化。我们彻底重做了厨房。正如大多数乌索尼亚住宅的情况一样，埃文家里的厨房是一个小凹室，非常高效，而且非常、非常小。
Right never realized that the whole family might actually want to hang out in the kitchen. Nowadays, it's as much a place to gather as the living room or the dining room. Evans has added new tiling and appliances and expanded his kitchen, but not by much. Well, we bumped that wall out by taking some closet space away, and we gained, I don't know, maybe 10 inches there. That's all that we gained in doing that. There are a smattering of usonian homes throughout the United States,
赖特从未意识到整个家庭可能真的想在厨房里消磨时光。如今，它和客厅或餐厅一样，是一个聚集的地方。埃文增加了新的瓷砖和电器，并扩建了他的厨房，但幅度不大。嗯，我们通过占用一些壁橱空间把那堵墙向外推了推，我们获得了，我不知道，大概10英寸的空间。这就是我们这样做所获得的全部。在美国各地散布着一些乌索尼亚住宅，
some designed by right and some by his apprentices, but all following the same basic principles. And like Evan Kingsley's home, many of these other usonian houses are hard to modify, because they're often governed by boards who are trying to preserve them as historic pieces of architecture. And also, the owners themselves want to make sure they keep within the principles of the house. You have X number of cabinets. You don't have cabinets up at the top. They weren't put there. And if you could add them, you would violate the principles.
有些是由赖特设计的，有些是由他的学徒设计的，但都遵循相同的基本原则。像埃文·金斯利的家一样，许多其他乌索尼亚住宅很难改造，因为它们通常由试图将其作为历史建筑保护起来的董事会管理。而且，业主自己也想确保他们保持在房屋的原则之内。你有X个橱柜。你不能在顶部安装橱柜。它们本来就没有放在那里。如果你加了它们，你就会违反原则。
There's no Frank Lloyd Wright police who come around and look and see if you change the own thought. That's a weird joke about but there isn't. That's Betty and John Moore. They live in Wisconsin and the house called Jacobs 2. It's the second Euconian house that Wright designed for that journalist Herbert Jacobs. Yeah well you want to make sure that you can adapt to the house because it's not going to adapt to you. You aren't going to change it much. Like most euconian homes, Jacobs too had a carport, big windows, and open plan in concrete floors with a heating system in it. The floor is nice and cool now, so. What's in the winter, you come downstairs with it. The floor is nice and cool now, so. What's the winner? You come downstairs and bear feet in the nice and warm.
没有所谓的“弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特警察”会到处查看你是否改变了原有的想法。那是个奇怪的笑话，但确实没有。那是贝蒂和约翰·摩尔。他们住在威斯康星州，住在一座叫“雅各布二号”的房子里。这是赖特为那位记者赫伯特·雅各布设计的第二座乌索尼亚住宅。是的，嗯，你要确保你能适应房子，因为它不会适应你。你不会改变它太多。像大多数乌索尼亚住宅一样，雅各布二号有车棚、大窗户、开放式平面图和带有供暖系统的混凝土地板。地板现在又凉又舒服，所以。冬天的时候，你光着脚下楼，又舒服又暖和。
I mostly wanted to play that clip because I love how Betty and John actually complete each other sentences. Betty and John's house needed a lot of attention, which is why it was on the market for four and a half years before they bought it. Oh, everybody wanted to look at it. It was a curiosity, but nobody wanted to live here. They've been really not for everyone, the reason they sit on the market sometimes for so long is because people consider them a difficult to live in. That's John Eifler, an architect in Chicago who has restored a number of right houses, including Yusonia One.
我播放这段录音主要是因为我喜欢贝蒂和约翰实际上互相补充对方句子的方式。贝蒂和约翰的房子需要很多关注，这就是为什么它在他们买下之前已经在市场上挂了四年半。哦，每个人都想看看它。它是一个好奇的对象，但没有人想住在这里。它们真的不适合每个人，它们有时在市场上挂那么久的原因是人们认为它们很难居住。那是约翰·艾夫勒，一位芝加哥的建筑师，他修复了许多赖特的房子，包括乌索尼亚一号。
In order to preserve them, you sometimes have to modify them in order to make them more livable. But even experts like Eiffler have a tough time keeping track of how many Usonian homes exist. So how many are there? I don't know. I don't know. I have no idea. I've heard numbers ranging from 27 to 140.
为了保护它们，你有时必须修改它们以使它们更适合居住。但即使是像艾夫勒这样的专家也很难追踪到底有多少乌索尼亚住宅存在。那么到底有多少呢？我不知道。我不知道。我一点头绪也没有。我听到的数字从27到140不等。
It all depends on your definition of what an authentic Euconian house is. You could consider Euconia a period in Frank Lloyd Wright's life, a period in American architectural history, which would include the houses by the apprentices, or just a general architectural style. Depending on your definition,
这完全取决于你对什么是正宗乌索尼亚住宅的定义。你可以把乌索尼亚看作弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特生命中的一个时期，美国建筑史上的一个时期，这可能包括学徒设计的房子，或者仅仅是一种通用的建筑风格。取决于你的定义，
the number of Euconian houses continues to grow. In 2013, a new Euconian house was built on the campus of Florida Southern College. It was a design of rights from 1939, but constructed 74 years later, all according to rights plans and principles. Euconia certainly never came to pass in the way that Frank Wood Wright originally envisioned, with every American living in an affordable custom home. And in fact, elements of the usonian home have evolved into something else entirely.
乌索尼亚住宅的数量还在继续增长。2013年，佛罗里达南方学院的校园里建造了一座新的乌索尼亚住宅。这是赖特1939年的设计，但在74年后才建成，完全按照赖特的计划和原则。乌索尼亚当然从未以弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特最初设想的方式实现，即每个美国人都住上负担得起的定制住宅。事实上，乌索尼亚住宅的元素已经演变成了完全不同的东西。
So it is kind of true that the usonia directly influenced the development of the ranch home. Oh, without a doubt, yes, I think so. Ranch-style houses are all over the country. And nearly every suburb, they are horizontal, close to the ground, one story. They have an open floor plan with few walls. So it's not hard to see the similarities to Euconia. Although ranch homes are generally less inspired. They don't have the elegant details, and they're made with standard materials.
所以乌索尼亚直接影响了牧场式住宅的发展，这种说法在某种程度上是真的。哦，毫无疑问，是的，我想是这样。牧场式住宅遍布全国。在几乎每个郊区，它们都是水平的，靠近地面，一层楼。它们有开放式的平面图，墙壁很少。所以不难看出它们与乌索尼亚的相似之处。尽管牧场式住宅通常灵感较少。它们没有优雅的细节，而且是用标准材料制成的。
Right might not have been pleased the concepts of euconia got absorbed into, essentially the epitome of cookie cutters of bourbon housing, but at least these houses really were affordable for the middle class, unlike all the euconia houses after euconia won. After World War II, the American suburbs were full of ranch homes. There weren't that many variations after the war, and the suburban ranch home was pretty much it. I mean, that, unless you were living in some humongous mansion or something, everyone was living in ranch homes in suburbia.
赖特可能不会高兴乌索尼亚的概念被吸收进了本质上是郊区住房的样板房缩影中，但至少这些房子对中产阶级来说确实负担得起，不像乌索尼亚一号之后的所有乌索尼亚住宅。第二次世界大战后，美国郊区到处都是牧场式住宅。战后没有太多的变化，郊区牧场式住宅基本上就是那样。我的意思是，除非你住在某个巨大的豪宅里，否则每个人都住在郊区的牧场式住宅里。
It was a very prevalent form of housing. Frank Lloyd Wright died in 1959 at age 89, three years after finishing Roland Reisley's house in New York. He died having created an American style for home building, a way in which natural wood, bricks and masonry are used in a simple, modifiable way, away that is cozy, stylish, organic, and honest. His influence is there where you see lots of wood and stone and where you see big, open floor plans, where homes are oriented to the sun or away from the street, where you see a structure built into a hill instead of on top of it, connected and responding to the landscape.
这是一种非常普遍的住房形式。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特于1959年去世，享年89岁，在他完成罗兰·赖斯利在纽约的房子三年后。他去世时创造了一种美式住宅建筑风格，一种以简单、可修改的方式使用天然木材、砖块和砖石的方式，一种舒适、时尚、有机且诚实的方式。他的影响随处可见，当你看到大量的木材和石头，当你看到巨大的开放式平面图，当房屋朝向太阳或背对街道，当你看到结构是建在山坡里而不是山顶上，与景观相连并与之呼应时。
And yes, whether he would have liked it or not, Franklin Wright's influence can be found in ranch homes and the suburbs and in the details of all kinds of homes, all around us and ways Wright never imagined. Eusonia lives on. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Avery Trouffleman, Music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is the senior producer Kurt Colstead is the digital director. Thres the team includes our senior editor Delaney Hall, Sheree Fusif, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful, downtown, Oakland,
是的，无论他是否喜欢，弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的影响力都可以在牧场式住宅、郊区以及我们周围各种房屋的细节中找到，以赖特从未想象过的方式。乌索尼亚永存。《99%隐形》本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。凯蒂·明格尔是高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队包括我们的高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔、谢丽·富西夫、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、塔伦·马扎、乔·罗森伯格、薇薇安·李、索菲亚·克拉茨克和我罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在美丽的奥克兰市中心电台街制作，
California. 99% invisible as a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Orc. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you want to drool over some usonia homes, look no further than 99PI.org.
加利福尼亚州。《99%隐形》是来自PRX的RadioTopia成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。在radiotopia.fm上可以找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIOrg。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但如果你想对一些乌索尼亚住宅垂涎三尺，看看99PI.org就够了。
Radio Tumpia. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
RadioTopia。RadioTopia。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。